how have you each been handling what the
whole world is going through right now
the nice thing is we're neighbors
so we've been keeping each other company
but I think the biggest thing is just
keeping each other calm and kind of just
helping each other out with our fears
and anxiety of the uncertainty of this
virus so I'm really lucky we have each
other yeah I agree with Bree we're just
trying to stay super positive and you
know also promote that as well because
you know this is a scary time and I
think any of us ever expected to go
through this in our lifetime so just
trying to keep our heads up high and
especially for our baby yeah you know
you know what I was gonna say is I mean
not only is that something none of us
ever expected to go through but I'm sure
you two didn't necessarily know you'd be
pregnant together and then be going
through a global pandemic pregnant
together how are you keeping each other
calm and healthy when you have that
added worry I mean I guess it's a good
thing that you can lean on each other
for having that same experience right
now
right definitely um you know we're lucky
because so Artem's here with us too and
he's been cooking a lot of our meals and
I think it's binding those because we
have each other it's been easy to
isolate and so and we did isolated I
want to say a week before they're even
really encouraging people to stay home
because being pregnant we are at a
higher risk having lower immune systems
so I think having each other and being
able to work from home but having Artem
who's like been doing a lot of fun
cooking his help and I have to say we
have increased our meditation so much
because you try not to panic
being pregnant because this is not how I
imagined my first pregnancy to be like
in the beginning I got influenced of me
right when I recovered from that we had
started just doing a few things with
work and then all of sin I had isolate
you know because the krona virus so I
imagined my first pregnancy to be a lot
different so I'm trying to embrace it
especially socially of like I mean I'm
already more than halfway through which
I can't believe so just try not the best
and I think the biggest thing for us is
keeping up on our nutrients we're really
trying to stay healthy and I think
that's the important thing for everyone
is that your immune
is can be strong as long as you allow it
to be so we just been upping our vitamin
intake eating super healthy staying
hydrated a lot of walks too then a lot
of what you're used to throwing down in
a ring and you're like we've never
walked to this much before
it's crazy like I literally just bought
an elliptical off of Amazon I think it's
like was $300 and it just got delivered
so I'm curious how that's gonna be but I
told Bri I'm like I need more activity
like walking is great but like I need
more I chased a toddler all day long and
play little activities with her so I
feel very like I'm getting on my exit
yeah yeah so tell me how it is working
then with you guys living next door to
each other and isolating who are you
coming in contact with and how are you
making all that work that you have you
kind of built a little compound and in
some ways we've definitely built a
compound and like my husband was a part
of it but unfortunately he had to go to
Orlando to film a bunch of WB stuff so
he's kicked out of the compound but we
literally we don't let family come over
we don't let anyone it's just been Artem
to pull Bertie and I and you know
birdies gonna be three May and I'm
trying the crunchy and the French cheese
and trying to explain to her why we've
been home and not out and about not
going to school not music class and she
has no idea but we have definitely built
a compound we enjoy our coffees in the
morning we switch having dinner at each
other's houses so it feels like we have
some where we're going yeah
so we definitely make the most of it
yeah so it's it's been yeah I feel bad
because sometimes family won't say now
but we've just been so strict cuz we've
been together since the beginning and
with Artem so we know like okay we've
all had the same contact so far right
it'll like Walking Dead would be so hard
that he had to go to Orlando how's that
been for you guys really hard I guess
you know it's nice not only to have
someone helping with birdie because like
you know my daughter wakes up early she
needs to be entertained all day and you
want to keep it like different and fun
but so not to have your husband there to
help out with that but also what was
nice is with he and Artem together
they're doing they're going out to
grocery store together making sure
everything was disinfected they're doing
a lot together like yeah like their
little man team yeah they were and it
would just the help was tremendous and
at the same time like you go through
this and you don't I feel safe around
town so to not have that makes me feel
like a little like though but and when
he comes home Brees making him stay in a
hotel for 15 days I would imagine that's
got to be pretty emotional I mean not
only not having the help but not having
the here husband a father of your child
there with you at a time when the world
is so uncertain yes oh it definitely is
and you know I told him I'm like I feel
bad he gets home this Thursday and and
he was gone a week and I was just like
you have to stay in the hotel you have
to be healthy Intel you realize you
don't have any symptoms I'm like and I
look at it like this is a small time I'm
praying it's a small time in our lives
to the rest of our lives and my number
one concern is my daughter and this baby
that comes in July so you're you're
settling in to say look I've got to be
okay with that I might not see you for
some time and we've got to do what's
best for the kids right now that was the
decision we both made because it was
hard for him to be like should I go to
SmackDown should I not I want my family
to be first but I told him I might you
know you and I at least with technology
can FaceTime FaceTime bird make videos
but we just have to both understand that
they might feel like a week trip but
really it's gonna be we could be months
away from each other and we have to be
okay with that
and at least it's not like he's going to
war when you think those men and women
who were drafted or you know would be
gone for so long you know
so Bernie's getting into a little face
time dates staying in touch with that oh
yeah he takes some like on these walks
she puts him in her stroller and then is
like dead I'm gonna walk you around or
takes him to her playground and puts him
on the swing and swings them on the
FaceTime but she builds like she's doing
these activities or things she sees his
head on the FaceTime it's actually
really cute
so you guys have kind of created a
beautiful little throuple now is artem
stepping up because I do see I don't
like Nikki you've Instagram and I'm the
saying you're like he's doing the
cooking and what is he doing to make you
both feel taken care of he's got two
pregnant lady's on his hands he's making
us battle he so he's been so attentive
like he puts out our vitamins every
morning
it's so cute cos he has just this thing
that you need your vitamins in your
system before you consume any food
he's been so amazing about reading this
same book to my belly to the baby
morning tonight have you learned new
things about each other is spending all
this time together or kind of
experienced even new realms of closeness
because this is an experience none of us
have had before I think it's showing us
on these sides of people oh my god true
the one thing that we are kind of
talking about is just realizing that her
and I run so hard we have companies and
we're always looking to just fill up our
plates so much and being forced to kind
of like relax and think about life and
where life could be headed with them
economy and everything we just kind of
said like we need to pull back a little
more like we need to really think about
like where our passion and the things we
want to dedicate our time to and so it's
kind of woken us up in that way that we
don't need to run as hard as like we
think right oh because I'll end up with
a lot of game plans
yeah like plans I should say that is I
mean we've talked about like a store
gonna open up an app though more older
and now you just we know that we could
like retire together and have wine every
night I thought we would have been
fighting more and it's crazy because
we're not we've actually really enjoyed
this time together of not having to like
like have a quick 10-minute coffee and
go run off because we're always doing
something and I'm the one who's such a
go-getter so it's really opened up my
eyes to just the important things of
life like how much I really have missed
like playing with birdie for like an
hour not just a quick 10 and then I'm
out are actually sitting and enjoying an
hour's worth of coffee
with the Sun freshly rising and hearing
the birds in the morning like those are
little things and I'm like whoa I've
been missing out or family dinner
sitting down and I wonder if that's open
up a lot of people's eyes I mean I don't
know if divorce rates gonna go up after
this yeah I mean we're all suddenly not
only together all the time but talking
about huge uncertain issues that could
affect the rest of our lives and you
know I think a lot of people are feeling
um the way to of having to cancel a lot
of things they had planned for those
selves and I don't know what's happened
with you guys with that but like in
preparing for baby and you know getting
a nursery going or planning baby showers
have you had to cancel or adjust
anything I mean when so live podcast or
our book drops may fit we had to cancel
our book tour and you know for books
that's really important or your tours um
we are getting inducted into the WWE
bout that got cancelled or even our baby
showers we're gonna have to postpone and
we're hoping it was like pretty much 20
20 Bri and I like this is an amazing
year for us and we were both like wow we
are slammed until the doctors say we
can't travel anymore but we're like how
amazing that we get to do all these
things like I was gonna do a few covers
of some pregnancy magazines all those
got cancelled and like so it's like
everything we are doing brought in
company yeah we've been total buzz
coming up April 2nd we were like her and
I plan because we had to do media in New
York in LA and we're like okay we'll
make these are little baby moon sister
baby moons and do some really fun stuff
and we also plan to Napa trip together
you're going to bottle rock so we little
baby moons together and then we had to
cancel her baby shower my spring pool so
weird it's now it's just kind of like
every day you just wake up hoping that
the virus will be contained in just kind
of a curve we'll just flatten instead of
waking up now and being like bummer
no baby shower another thing so now we
have we're going to go into giving birth
to these babies with them I I did want
to ask you guys because I have some
friends who are about to go into labor
and I can't imagine what it's like to
have that fear of going into a hospital
right now and what they're hearing is
in many places they're being told only
one person in the room with you you know
what your family can't come have you
guys thought about that this would
extend I know you stopped some months
ahead but I don't know if you've thought
about your birth plans at all with with
how this might affect things definitely
I know like our demand I have top
because I told him I'm like you know I'm
happy our baby's coming beginning of
August and I feel really bad for the
people that are due over the next few
weeks but I told the artemon like it's a
scary time to just be in the hospitals I
mean your doctors are getting
coronavirus by just working on patients
so you just it's almost scary to go in a
hospital than anywhere else right now
and I told him I was like that really
worries me about you know maybe I think
are we gonna have to have it at home but
I don't want a natural birth so it
worries me and I just told him I guess
where we are lucky because we are
beginning of August so I pray every
morning a knife but it changes for us um
as a now we're still like due to have
her baby in LA we have a reservation at
the hospital so I'm praying that all
stays yeah I mean I would birdie I I had
a really hard labor and and an emergency
c-section so for myself I my biggest
fear of this pregnancy was if I could
have a VBAC like could I do a vaginal
birth after having a c-section and now
I'm like my biggest fear is going to the
hospital and like you said no family and
I would love to do a VBAC I might have
another c-section and then you're in a
surgery room so you're closer to where
there are victims of the chronovisor so
there's so much well and probably your
your body's already sort of I mean I've
never been pregnant but the hormones and
the way your body's feeling like are you
guys extra emotional with everything
that's happening yes I did I definitely
like I cry every few days I just have to
like get it out and I feel bad for artim
because I feel like sometimes I get a
little bit of a short fuse to something
I just you know what it is is if I don't
like I'm getting enough attention from
him it's like I just need it's like
something that I need so then I feel bad
cuz I get really hard on him like
shaking her head like yeah this is
exactly how she liked our dobutsu here
this whatever you're emitting it what he
just needs to give me more attention I
have never my life had such a passionate
connection with someone
[Music]
I really like kid being a part of this
family
they open oh my total Bella's coming
back April 2nd right what can you expect
from this season was it all films before
everything started it was so thank
goodness it was our last day was by
anyway yeah but we'll breathe I think
you should start this season was
definitely like it was hard on me a
little bit because I feel like my
husband died with reality television I'm
leaving gene for over seven years now
and we put our whole eggs out there but
we never just thought about opening up
our marriage the way we did this season
and I mean all med our last year has
been struggles it's been a little bit of
a struggle since birdie came to the
picture I know I could have a better
marriage you think you and Bryan are
meant to be don't stay because you have
children it does do more damage than
good he and I are still trying to learn
how to balance like being parents and
stopping passion but then having these
careers that we book on the road and
we're going different directions and at
times we feel like single parents so we
really looked the cameras in on our
marriage and it was really hard to watch
back because I didn't realize kind of
how much we've lost and just to try to
bring that back and so we showcase that
a lot and I know I saw a lot of my fans
just being like wait what and it's like
yeah we all go through it it's really
hard to balance like being like just a
wife and a career woman and a mother
yeah but with that it's like I feel like
people are gonna be like Nikki's so
confused because like here I'm like on
cloud nine and this new amazing
relationship and we get engaged and you
know that was really fast for me
but very exciting too but then literally
a week or two weeks later I found out I
was pregnant and like I was already when
we came back from France it started to
settle in then I was engaged and then I
was like kind of freaking out like oh my
god I'm engaged like I don't know and
then when I found out I was pregnant
it's just like people unless you're in
it you don't realize the emotional
roller coaster that has on you because
it's like I just got hit with it all at
once all the things that I want in my
life it just all came and I was like so
I through that and there's a lot of
amazing stuff you know with Artem and I
and then you do see that struggle and I
feel like they're gonna she's just so
confused but it's it's just Bree and I
were real every season and we were even
like that on divas I think that's what
helped us you know get our spin Austin
but this season becomes very raw you'll
see our dad for the first time that
causes a lot of family trauma and I'm
really excited for the world to get to
know Artem because you've just always
seen him you know in Dancing with the
Stars and it's more about the celebrity
and not pro and he's so Russian and like
so different you know the cameras were
there when Artem got cut from Dancing
with the Stars which was like shocking
to all of us and just his emotion that
was really saddened to see him just this
whole season kind of struggle to
actually yeah who else he is also dance
was totally because he was like like
what's my purpose now and I think
because it was his first time with
reality TV and he's coming in aren't him
from Dancing with the Stars and so proud
and literally they cut him two days
before he was leaving a GMA like lie
inside it and so you see a struggle this
season which time I need you to struggle
for us because it's really hard when
you're like you guys feel like you're on
top of the world and then when a man
loses his job like he just felt like he
lost a lot of confidence and you see
that this season and it's sad but you
see that struggle are you being serious
let's show you something twins pregnant
at the same time I'm shocked are you
shocked
so his mama where were you guys trying
for a baby or was it was it totally a
surprise so totally so a month before
which we actually filmed this I was
filling all these weird symptoms so I
went to the doctor and I got my blood
flow tested and they found out I had
PCOS so I had like no estrogen to my
body I was like fluid testosterone which
BRE was like a force so they wanted to
put me on medication and then they told
me they're like you have to freeze your
eggs because you will not be able to
have children you'll have to have help
and you need to do that now because
where I was at with the PCOS any time I
would have should put sugar in my system
it was killing off my eggs so I started
a plan before we went to France I was
like in November I was gonna get my eggs
start the process of freezing my eggs so
I'll admit there were two nights where I
would didn't use protection because I'm
like I can't get pregnant
there's no estrogen bullet testosterone
it took just one or I guess one of the
two to get pregnant so that's why I was
so shocked because I mean I wasn't
tracking there was nothing and my
periods were like I mean they were there
but it was just weird
I don't even when I went back to my
doctor because it literally was like
four or five weeks later she's like no
no there's no way and she every time she
sees me at work she you know she always
says like always cause my baby a miracle
baby because she will go back and look
at my blood test and she's like I just
don't see how it's possible how this
happened I don't know if it's a Russian
thing it's a Latin thing you put it
together I don't know what happened I
feel like it's some type of spiritual
thing because I was shocked by my
pregnancy which I found out two days
before her and we both were off in
France and we just figured you know
drinking too much wine not realizing we
both were actually pregnant but we Ryan
and I I mean it took us a while to get
pregnant with birdie
we tried eight months to get pregnant
the baby and then made the decision we
are only meant
have one kid and after he got back from
a Sedona trip and it was before he was
headed literally to Europe the night
before we had like just a fun night and
we weren't careful because it's not easy
for us so I had the same feeling she did
which is what made us laugh because I
was like wait a second I'm pregnant that
doesn't know I had she told me I was
like hell yeah I know I was mindfully so
incomparable your book that's coming out
in May right um I'm sure fans are gonna
be bummed they won't get to see you do a
full book tour so what do you want them
to know about what they'll get out of
this book oh I just say in the book
you're gonna definitely hear stories
that we've never told before we've never
showcased on reality TV in our lives I
mean it's just a lot of hard things we
went through as children and growing up
and even me becoming a woman and certain
things like we go into detail about how
we lost our virginity and other stories
about that and I think to see brie and I
have always had a part of us because we
were just raised to be survivors and not
victims and we always felt like well if
we shared a true story does that make us
a victim and what we've realized being
in the spotlight now for 13 years and
being reality stars for seven is that
people like to know they're not alone
when they go through certain situations
I think that really opened to my eyes
through my breakup it was so hard to
showcase that and live through it but I
can't tell you how many women and men
constantly come up to me like thank you
for showcased that because you helped me
get through what I went through I think
fans are gonna be shocked by that you
know what we went through I agree and I
and our like big thing for her and I was
just like you know childhood isn't easy
and sometimes as children we hang on to
the really bad stuff and sometimes it me
you know it out plays the good and we
want just young women and men to just
understand that like childhood is
difficult it is hard to just grow into
this person that you're trying to figure
out and we just want to leave kids in
the right path Nikki sounds like a lots
gonna come out in the book have you have
you called John and
- and said these things might come out
about our relationship or how do you
handle that
well because of contracts inside he had
anything right so he's he read his
chapter he headed it it's yeah it
couldn't anything that I do with him has
to go through approval through him so
okay okay improved I mean I don't know
like you you guys seem like you're such
a mature incredible women and you you
kept that side of the street clean and
you guys see my drunkard yeah yeah and
Bree I want to ask you you mentioned
something before that it's just kind of
sticking in my mind now but what we'll
see this season with you and your
husband and you said something you've
lost will come out do you mean kind of
that like that connection between you
two or what are you talking about cuz I
do think a lot of people go through how
parenting changes their relationships
you know I think the biggest thing for
Bryan a what we lost is we used to as a
couple we evolved together it was like
the same way you want to live the same
views you just feel like the growth
happens together and it's growth I felt
with her you know like growing as
business partners together it's tag-team
and when we realized becoming parents we
start to evolve different and our once
in life the things that we visualize our
future became very different and he and
I both were used to that because from
dating to our first couple years of
marriage it was all the same and it
starts making me lose connections
because what we start to realize is our
conversations weren't as deep anymore or
I started realizing I didn't have as
much interest in what he was saying and
he didn't have as much interest as what
I was saying and it you lose that and it
was weird to like lose the passion and
then the interest and then evolving
together and that's what we really had
to start working on and I always thought
to myself marriage should be nothing you
ever work on it should just be the one
easy thing oh yeah right it's like the
one thing you need to work on and I
finally realized that my life in the
last year like if I don't work on my
marriage Brian and I will be done and he
and I both started to realize like how
real our relationship could end if we
don't start paying at first
thank you guys so
so good to see both of you stay safe and
stay healthy I'm glad you have Artem
cooking for you I see that burn on your
hand I saw that on his thumb can you but
it's so bad this is for making toast
that's why we keep her out of the
kitchen I used to be bad you can't watch
we love you guys entertainment tonight's
audience loves you thank you both so
much bye bye
[Music]